hey welcome to a new project camp update
video in this video is highly requested
by you guys we're going to do a review
on our battery-powered electric chainsaw
and brush cutter
you guys have been asking for it but we
didn't make review yet because we wanted
to give a real review after really using
the tool for a longer period of time so
this is one year later
both machines are makita battery powered
just to point it out we're not sponsored
we actually try to remove the brands as
much as we can
because we just want to give an unbiased
opinion and make sure yeah we're not
sponsored or need to say anything
so yeah in this video we're going to
have a look at them we're going to do a
contest also between an electric and a
gas powered one we're going to test them
and see all the pros and cons but in
order to start this whole review we need
to go back one year in
[Music]
time so in today's update we have
something new
it's an electric chainsaw
i never really worked with an electric
chainsaw before they sound kind of
impressive to me
less noise that's the main reason why we
have it and it doesn't run on fossil
fuels
so in this video i want to put it
together
test it and a few things i'm
particularly interested in is how long
does it actually last because one saw
has two batteries and i have six
batteries in total so i can have three
sessions and i'm curious yeah how long
before they're empty how much noise does
it make
and also how i don't know how robust and
sturdy this machine feels feels a bit
like a toy almost when you hear it a
small but important note this video is
not sponsored by makita we bought the
machine by people supporting on patreon
you might wonder why we did get a makita
basically because all our power tools
are already
running on that battery system so we
kind of locked into that system
which in a way feels bad because you're
stuck in an ecosystem and might not
choose the best saw but you just choose
it because it fits the rest but that's
in a way is also the powerful thing that
once you have a battery you can use it
on your different devices i guess that's
ups and down sides so we're going to
chop down some bushes some trees that i
didn't do last time
big small wet old new fresh
all sorts of trees so we have the saw
cardboard cardboard
chain chain oil
thing that holds the chain
and the batteries which we already had
ourselves
[Applause]
so we're going to start off simple by
chopping some dead trees
not sure if you've seen this in update 3
i made a few pathways
right there but i left quite a bunch of
bigger trees over there because i didn't
really want to cut them
so now i'm going to clean this all up
and chop them with a chainsaw
this looks like a good first cut
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
wow that's kind of impressive actually
[Music]
so the pod is now clear went
surprisingly fast actually
the saw itself looks good bit dusty
battery life is two dots whatever that
means i mean i'm kind of surprised
actually how smooth this went
but to be fair
these are already dead trees they burned
down a few years ago so in a way
i would say an easy score as well
so for the next part we're going to the
swamp because a few weeks ago i cleaned
it and i took out a lot of trees
and all those trees need to be chopped
into smaller trees so this test is
basically to just do a lot of cutting so
here are a bunch of trees and i'm just
gonna chop them down
[Music]
new batteries
[Music]
all right so all the wood is now chopped
quite a lot actually went super fast and
super smooth maybe it's just because
it's new that it's all fun but i'm kind
of still surprised how smooth it goes
halfway in the batteries were empty so
we had to change them just swap in other
ones and it's done also that's smooth
and now the battery is half empty again
so i would say doing all of this took me
one battery pack so two batteries in
total
so now we go to the next part where
we're gonna chop just a few bigger
trees and finally we have this pile you
might have seen it in the update tree
where i make the pathways but this was
such a big pile of just trees that i
never cleaned it so we always walk over
it which is far from my deal not proud
of it but uh yeah maybe now is the time
to clean that up
so for this test we have one full
battery
and i'm just going to put on a time
lapse and chop and see how fast it goes
and how much battery it takes to get rid
of this pile
[Music]
so this job is not finished yet
and i'm out of batteries now i did work
a bit intensively a lot of thick boot in
a very short time
um but yeah the job is just not finished
yet and the batteries are empty and with
a normal chainsaw you could just add
fuel and continue and with this one you
have to recharge so i'll continue
tomorrow which is perfectly fine for me
but if you're in the middle in the job i
could see that being a bit annoying
but yeah for now since we can't cut
anyway let's open this one up to see how
it's made
ah
so uh final verdict i would say it's a
pretty good saw
and nice to work with but i would also
say don't really believe anything i'm
saying because i'm not at all
experienced with chainsaws and it's the
first time i'm using it so obviously
everything is exciting and everything is
still good and proper i think the test
is really over time like is it still
durable after a while does everything
stay properly stuff doesn't break so i
would say make sure to uh remind me in a
year or something to make review or to
to talk about this thing because then i
could give a real honest review
about it but i would say so far so good
alright so here we are one year later
this is what the saw looks like now a
bit more worn out we used it heavily
but still functions as it did before
i actually forgot to mention before the
model it's a duc-353
in case you're curious
and as we were using this throughout the
year we actually also bought
an electric brush cutter because same
battery system we kind of liked working
with the electric tool so we got one of
these as well
this one is the dur 3
6 9 a
um so i'm going to show a little bit as
well
how this one has been used and whether
we like it or not because we've also
been using it for a year but looking
back at the footage uh
one year ago from this side i was kind
of excited when we got it because it
felt super powerful
quick cuts but that was also because i
was mainly comparing it with a hansa so
yeah obviously a chainsaw is a bit more
superior than this one
but what i actually needed to do
don't compare it with a handsaw but
compared with a gas chainsaw because
this is kind of the competitor of this
one
and this is a saw we got from a friend
and we have been using this electric saw
both throughout the whole year we've
been using both so now we have a pretty
good reference between how they compare
to each other
and i would say the main thing that is
different is actually just the power
this thing has way more power than this
one
but let me actually show you in a little
contest if we're gonna use this one
compared to this one to see what the
difference is
so here we have our setup here we have
one big lock we chopped in the middle
and then we put them like this so this
side is exactly the same as this side
we're gonna chop them with a gasa and an
electric saw and we're gonna see which
one is fastest to start how long
can they cut which one cuts the fastest
so we're just going to start and you
guys can see how it's going to be
you can count
how many starts yeah
okay
three two one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how many did you have
i had a biscuit that rolled away
one 90
9 10 11
12
and a half
and once if you have a super sharp thing
also in the beginning it got [ __ ]
sick but if it's not very sharp it cuts
not good at all and this one still cuts
they seem pretty similar now the only
way to settle this is a battle and then
we just [ __ ] gear up and then it can
cut seeds
right so the winner is this one tim cut
13 slices i got nine in the same time
and my battery is almost empty as well
so i would have to stop soon where tim
could continue
so yeah let's say this one has a bit
more power
now back to the review
okay so here we have the pro and cone of
this machine
and the pro is it's quite quiet compared
to the gas powered machine
so sound twice it's much less it's also
much easier to start here you just press
a button and you're good to go with the
gas eye you have to pull the cord a few
times
also depending if the motor is hot or
cold
so yeah it takes a bit more effort to do
which makes this uh also as a third pro
very friendly to use
especially people here that haven't
worked much for the chainsaw this is
much easier to just grab and you take it
and you cut something
and finally also it just doesn't use any
gas which is kind of magical
it just runs on electricity and in our
case solar so in a way it's just free
energy flowing in
so you can use it
as much as there is energy available
downsides of this uh it's empty quick
it runs on two batteries but once the
batteries are empty you have to recharge
them
and this takes a while and meanwhile you
can't do anything unless you have more
batteries
it's not as powerful we've been mainly
chopping here young
fresh trees
which are kind of easy to cut compared
to a thick old tree so it's good to cut
some basic little things but if you
really want to cut a lot
it will be challenging with this one
and it's also hard to fix like
mechanically parts like the chain are
the same and the locking mechanisms but
the whole motor is all electrical driven
so if something is broken you can't fix
it like with a combustion engine you
really have to bring it to makita where
you can change it or replace it
so those are about the differences
between the two types of saw but they
actually also have a lot of similarities
both have a break both have a handle
both
have a chain and a mechanism to cut and
both also need to use the chainsaw oil
actually one little tip on that you also
have this thing called biodegradable oil
which i would recommend seems nicer if
you cut in the middle of nature
and one extra other tip i would also
have in terms of sharpening the chains
so you kind of need to sharpen the
chains after using the chainsaw
and usually you do this with a file so
you go over the teeth and you sharpen it
but there's kind of an art to it
especially in the setting with us where
multiple people use the chainsaw you
don't want one person to clean it all
the time but learning how to clean a
chainsaw can be quite challenging
because you need to have the angle right
to make sure you sharpen it so we also
discovered this tool
which we like a lot actually because it
sort of explains how to sharpen it and
this thing defines the angle so it make
sure you put it perpendicular to the
chain and you always go in the right
direction
you make sure it's horizontal and it
also chops down this smaller part here
in front of the chain which you usually
actually with this one probably wouldn't
even sharpen
but every now and then you also need to
do that to really make sure the chain is
sharp so this tool does all of that so
it's very easy for people that not very
experienced with a chainsaw to sharpen
the chain after using it
just a little tip if you work with
multiple people would recommend this
thing
okay so that was a rough review for the
chainsaw
next we're gonna go quickly over the
brush cutter as well a lot of similarity
but also a few differences so let me
show you
all right so here we have the brush
cutter
and
looks pretty similar to the usual brush
cutter as with the chainsaw except this
one works on battery also slides in two
batteries same as the chainsaw and then
you have two three different speeds uh
that you can use
we've been using this one for over a
year as well uh we've done a lot of uh
rough things with it i would say a few
complications with it as well here the
plastic cover broke i would say it's on
us because
probably some stone or something chopped
in there
doesn't really seem to be
the issue of the machine
however we did have two electrical
issues as well one was right after we
bought it and one a few weeks ago
and then it just gives an error you
can't really do anything besides
bringing it to makita and then it was a
nice service it came back a few weeks
later
but
yeah that was a bit of the downsides and
for this machine it works also pretty
similar as the usual brush cutter so you
have a few blades you can use let me
actually show those
[Music]
so when we first started brush cutting
we had all these different kinds of
blades and we didn't really know what
they meant or how to use them for what
purpose so i'm quickly going to show you
because i think it's very useful
information when you start brush cutting
so you have a string cutter like this
with a little nylon cord and it's good
for chopping grass but the moment you
want to chop something thicker this
breaks which is not ideal it also leaves
plastic around
so you need something bigger for what we
like to use is this uh triangular blade
this is kind of an all-rounder it's good
in just chopping can drop thicker things
it's also good for mulching so you can
really uh make whatever you're gonna cut
small so it could drop grass but also
more like rumbles
like bigger things
if you really want to cut a lot of
rumbles which we've been doing a lot
like big pushes above you you can use a
blade like this
with the
blades going downwards because you can
really go from top to bottom and it sort
of chops everything
underneath there
it's a bit more aggressive to use but
very effective for these big brumbles
and then you also recently had it play
with this blade
it feels very rough to me it's just a
circular saw blade
um just spinning there in front of you i
guess i'm used to working with table
saws where everything is very fixed and
safe and protection covers and here you
are just swinging with a blade but this
mainly used to chop more smaller trees
and branches in front of you so you can
just sort of have a yeah i guess a saw
in front of you chopping the things
the blade we use mainly is this one
because a bit of an all-rounder you can
go to things like grass but also thicker
uh bushes instead of just chops and we
also like to use this one if we really
take on big brumbles
the blade itself the saw blades don't
like it and this one every now and then
if we really do the grass
but yeah this is just standard
information for brush cut just not
specifically for electric ones
so now let's get back to why this
electric one is different than the gas
one all right so here we have the review
of the brush cutter the pros and the
cons
they're pretty similar to the chainsaw
as in it's also less noisy because
electric
it's easier to start and it doesn't use
any gas so you can just run it on
electricity which is cool
the downside is
yeah also hard to repair
you can't really open it up and it
doesn't last super long the battery life
so the endurance is not very high
however the main difference is it does
have enough power it really feels like
it's good and like with the chainsaw
so those were the two reviews of the
brush cutter and the chainsaw now let me
give you a final verdict of both of
these electric machines
all right so here's the final verdict of
these two machines used for one year in
our setting
so big plus for us is that they just
make less noise because we're here with
many people on this land so you easily
disturb each other so the less noise
they make the better second one is it's
quite friendly to use
because you don't need to deal with the
gas the starting the choking the hot the
cold engine also you can
the moment you don't use it you don't
have to have it run idle you can just
turn it off and turn it back on again
when you need it which makes this whole
process much more friendly than with a
gas powered device i mean it's running
on solar which is the main reason why we
have it actually it's we're here off
grid so we can just use the electricity
we harvest directly in the machines it's
kind of magical and they're pretty good
to just quickly do something
because you just pick up the machine and
you start you don't have this whole
starting of the guest
powered machine now two main downsides i
would say the chainsaw is a little bit
of a joke if you really want to change
some bigger trunks or a lot of them it's
nice in between here and there but if
you really want a chainsaw for multiple
hours in a row
i wouldn't recommend this thing
the brush cutter has less of this
problem it feels like it's really made
for the job but the downside both of
them has is that they consume quite a
lot of batteries and for us it's less of
a problem because we have already this
whole makita system with a lot of
batteries but if you don't have that you
need to buy a lot of batteries to make
sure once they're empty that you can
keep going and keep swapping them
and besides that the charging just also
takes time so with the gas you can just
keep on going all the time and here you
might need to wait
for your batteries to be charged
but besides that i would say
nice machines to have my personally i
would i really like the brush cutter
because uh it's just smooth compared to
a gas powered one to work with
quickly starts quickly stops i like it
chainsaw it's nice to have around but i
noticed myself but every now and then i
still use the hand saw if you want to
just cut something smaller and if it's
thick it's still too small for that but
that's just my personal opinion
and yeah that was the review of our
electric sauce and
[Music]
that's it
potato time
all right so that was it for the review
video
and now sharpening chainsaw something
you always have to do after using it
and if you like the review let us know
because we could make more reviews like
this in the future with some tools we're
using
and next week we're probably going to
start renovating the rune again take out
some
big pieces there
if you only want to see that video make
sure to support on patreon so you can
see the video one week ahead if not
we'll just see you again next week at
the same time same channel
thanks for watching see you next week
[Music]
hmm